[Musik]
gewaltig rauchen sie noch die
thyssenkrupp-türme am Duisburger Rhein
hier entsteht noch Stahl mit Technik aus
dem 19 und 20 Jahrhundert Gewinn bringt
das kaum noch Steuergelder halten das
Ganze am laufen und die Zukunft sieht
nicht mehr rosig aus
Energiekosten sind explodiert
Weltkonzerne wie BASF wandern nach China
ab mit Ausnahme von SAP hat Deutschland
keine digitalen Riesen der neuen Zeit
die Autos der Zukunft kommt von Tesla
und aus dem fernen Osten
gerade im alten Westen ist der
Niedergang besonders sichtbar
wild ist durch Orte im reinen Ruhrgebiet
gereist und hat dem Volk aus Maul
geschaut wie der Reformator Martin
Luther das einst nannte es zeigte sich
viele Menschen haben Angst ohne Glauben
genau zu merken dass etwas schief läuft
und dann müssen Sie auch wichtig ist
brauchen die afd-sachen
ich bin von 60 Euro Strom auf 150 €
hochgestuft worden also
ich arbeite im Prinzip um mein Auto zu
tanken mein Strom zu bezahlen und meine
Wohnung zu bezahlen wenn die ersten
großen Firmen weggehen ins Ausland gehen
dann ist das Geschrei groß und dann
heißt es denn wie konnte das denn nur
passieren aber das ist das ist
Deutschland wir sind irgendwie
Land der Dichter und Denker das ist
vorbei es sind viele Gelder in Osten
geflossen und viele Baustellen die im
Westen waren sind dann halt geblieben
und der Wettbewerb zwingt die
Unternehmen möglichst kostengünstig
anzubieten und wenn die Rentabilität mit
Möglichkeit am Standort Deutschland
nicht mehr gegeben ist dann denken wir
und mehr Unternehmen nicht nur ans
Aufhören an die geschäftsschließung
sondern verlagern auch
im geografischen Zentrum des Ruhrpotts
in Wanne-Eickel ist eine der letzten
Kneipen das Schauen Mama mal
hier tranken früher die Kohle Brüder aus
den Zechen jetzt kommen immer noch
einfacher Arbeiter und Rentner
die Leute hier sagen woran es ihrer
Meinung nach Kranken in Deutschland an
ihren Geldbörsen sehen Sie das
tagtäglich
[Musik]
obwohl fast 400.000 Fachkräfte fehlen
liegt die Arbeitslosenquote hier bei
11%. Expert man Noris sagt was ihm auf
dem Herzen liegt Ruhrpott
[Musik]
schwer arbeiten guter Tage man hat kein
Geld geschickt bekommen Noris ärgert
sich über die Politik
was verdienen gearbeitet
was wird in Sanktion für ihre Arbeit und
Asylbewerber kommt rüber der kriegte
Wohnung der kriegt eine Handy der kriegt
tatsächlich nicht alles okay
[Musik]
geht ja die Häuser geht kaputt
ähnlich wie Norris sieht es auch Tanja
die nach ihrer Tresen Frühschicht ein
Feierabendbierchen trinkt gerade hier
sind eigentlich hier die hier hinkommen
alles nur einfache Arbeiter keine
hochbetuchten Leute
Rentner und ist klar die haben natürlich
auch nicht so viel laufe Tasche wie
jetzt jemand der da irgendwo eine Firma
leitet oder weiß ich nicht glaubst du
dass die Politiker diese einfachen Leute
genug haben überhaupt nicht warum kannst
du das mal erklären
die haben immer so tolle Vorschläge und
sage ich jetzt mal rein in ihrem Büros
und keine Ahnung und haben das echte
Leben überhaupt nicht also im Blick also
die die denken immer so ja wir machen
jetzt mal was weiß ich
einfach mal die Steuern für Schritt
höher und wissen aber nicht die Leute
wissen teilweise gar nicht mehr wie sie
das bezahlen sollen und zur Arbeit zu
kommen um ihr Geld zu verdienen damit es
halt wieder also die
Lebenshaltungskosten sind sowas von
gestiegen und das haben die Leute halt
einfach mit dem Blick die sehen halt
nicht dass die damit einfach den
einfachen Mann Beute
auch sie wundert nicht dass die
rechtsaußenfischen der AFD immer mehr
Anhänger gewinnt
die die reden denn einfachen Leuten
natürlich nach dem Mund also wie soll
ich das die dienen die kritisieren halt
die jetzige Politik und die einfachen
Leute natürlich die glauben das ja auch
ne also da ist eine Partei die kümmert
sich um uns die will uns Gutes tun das
was die da hinten machen das ist nicht
in Ordnung und die reden halt dagegen
das passt
ist doch klar dass sie dann stärker
werden gerade sage ich mal in den
neueren Bundesländern wo wo die Schwelle
zum ich sag mal in die Ecke einfach noch
geringer ist als hier also im Moment
weiß ich ganz ehrlich wenn ich jetzt
also wenn morgen Wahlen wären ich würde
nicht eine Partei werden weil mich alle
enttäuscht haben die AFD würde ich auf
gar keinen Fall werden ja weil die die
mir einfach zu weit rechts im Moment ist
CDU CSU SPD grün ganz schlimm also
bevor ich die sehe
weiß ich nicht mache ich mein Kreuz
lieber bei der hundepartei
[Musik]
Michael arbeitet als Lehrer in Dortmund
er hat das Gefühl seine Ruhe hat wird im
besonderen Maße im Stich gelassen
also hier müsste auch mal wieder so eine
Konzept für den Westen den fließen also
nicht nur das in den neuen Bundesländer
Geld geht oder das irgendwelche
chip-fabriken in der Nähe von Dresden
gebaut werden ja es ist in den letzten
Jahren da so viel Geld geflossen in den
Osten dass ich das Gefühl habe dass
dieses Gebiet hier vernachlässigt worden
ist man tut zwar etwas aber man kommt
gegen die Schwierigkeiten die entstehen
gar nicht an und deswegen müssen wir
richtig hier Geld reinfließen
in Deutschland wird so viel Geld
ausgegeben viele andere Dinge und hier
fehlt es einfach
[Musik]
Iris ist gerade in Rente gegangen sie
hat ihr Leben lang hart gearbeitet und
das würde eigentlich nicht reichen sagt
sie
ich bin ein ruhrpott-kind ganz klar und
die Politik ist ganz einfach so dass die
ja viele von uns im Stich lässt
fakt ist ähm ich bin seit Februar in
Rente
bin im Januar 63 geworden und ich könnte
oder hätte nicht in Rente gehen können
wenn ich keine Witwenrente beziehen
würde und ich habe 45 Jahre voll ich
habe mehr als 30 Jahre in der Pflege
gearbeitet und ich finde das kann nicht
sein dass ich dann
nicht in Rente gehen kann wenn
Politiker in einer Legislaturperiode als
Abgeordnete im Bundestag nach vier
Jahren
5000 Euro Rente bekommen oder mehr
katja ist knapp über 30 schuftet in
einer Autowaschanlage sie hat noch ein
ganzes Arbeitsleben vor sich
schwer vor allem als Frau mit Kind
alleine
aber wenn ich mal ein tiefer gehe in die
Kneipe
hier sind Freunde wir sind Familie wir
halten zusammen
ich habe eine 60 Quadratmeter Wohnung
bin von 60 Euro Strom auf 150 €
hochgestuft worden also
ich arbeite im Prinzip um mein Auto zu
tanken mein Strom zu bezahlen und meine
Wohnung zu bezahlen ne
ansonsten
100 € los ich arbeite viel weil ich
Leitungen bin
arbeitet bei 2.200 Stunden und habe eine
6 raus
dafür muss ich aber oft mein Kind
alleine lassen
schon schwer 50 Stunden muss Katja jede
Woche arbeiten gehen und den
Lebensunterhalt für sich und Ihr Kind zu
bestreiten Iris wundert nicht dass viele
dann lieber das Geld vom Staat nehmen
dann kann ich besser zu Hause
bleiben nur den Satz da kann man die
Leute doch verstehen wenn die sagen ich
bleibe mit dem Arsch zu Hause
[Musik]
doch mal also
drei vier fünf
Regelungen bundesweit nicht einheitliche
rauchergesetze etwa
für jede Zigarette muss er mit dem
Rollstuhl vor die Tür nervig für den
Kettenraucher
dabei
haben die Eltern vermutlich angenommen
können
[Musik]
Zukunft nichts das ist kein Perspektive
in diesem Land
[Musik]
ist Autoglaser er will trotz alledem
Arbeiten nicht auf Hartz IV angewiesen
sein
[Musik]
manchmal denkt man auch ja warum gehe
ich eigentlich arbeiten aber Hartz IV
helfen sich die Leute mit der Monat
nichts mehr in der Tasche
im Vergleich ist das Leben in
Deutschland aber noch sehr gut denkt sie
nachdem er neulich eine Dokumentation
über Armut in Indien sah
Bilder die dem Vater nicht mehr aus dem
Kopf gehen und ihn berührt haben
dein Müll mit so einem selbstgebauten
Baracken mit Folie mit dem Dächer
die haben wirklich im müllgelände
für eine Mann haben die gearbeitet der
das dann weiterverkauft hat und wir
haben da keine Ahnung so und so viel
bewegen glaube ich verdient und
dann haben die da auch gelebt die Leben
da im Müll wenn man sowas sieht dann
denkt man Gott sei Dank uns geht's gut
Ortswechsel Uedesheim bei Neuss hier
liegt ein Aluminiumwerk am Rhein das
aufgrund der gestiegenen Strompreise
komplett schließen soll
es ist ein Beispiel für den Niedergang
des Industriestandorts Deutschland die
energieintensive Aluminiumproduktion
wäre nur noch durch extreme Subvention
der Regierung machbar
2024 läuft ein Langzeitvertrag für
günstigen Industriestrom aus spätestens
dann soll Schluss sein
wer mit Arbeitern redet die Feierabend
haben und teils im Werkswohnungen nahe
des Fabrikgeländes Leben hört die
Frustration raus bevor ein
Sicherheitsmann des Werks der
zwischenfunktion und ihnen einen
Maulkorb verpasst sagt einer noch seine
Arbeitgeber habe teils günstigen
Industriestrom an der Börse verkauft
statt Alu zu produzieren und dafür
Angestellte in Kurzarbeit geschickt
jetzt müssen wohl 300 Kollegen gehen
von einem Unternehmenssprecher des
Betreibers Bayram heißt es zu Bild ohne
einen wettbewerbsfähigen
industriestrompreis soll das ganze halt
nicht mehr machbar
im Ortsteil Uedesheim der idyllisch an
einer Rheinschleife liegt redet der
Rentner Norbert offen darüber was ihn
ärgert er glaubt die hohen Energiepreise
liegen nicht nur am Angriffskrieg
Russlands auf die Ukraine und den damit
eingebrochenen Gasimporten sondern sein
von der Bundesregierung auch hausgemacht
danken die Damen und Herren in Berlin
herzlichen Dank die sind für diese
ganzen Strompreise da zuständig in
anderen Länder ist der Strom billiger
der wird teilweise von hier verschenkt
ein Schirm der Böses denkt wenn die
ersten großen Firmen weggehen ins
Ausland gehen dann ist das Geschrei groß
und dann heißt es denn wie konnte das
denn nur passieren aber das ist das ist
Deutschland wir sind irgendwie
im Land der Dichter und Denker das ist
vorbei tut mir leid das ist so meine
persönliche Meinung andere Länder
Schweden baut glaube ich 20 Steuer
Atomkraftwerke
laut Norbert gebe es auch grüne Strom
Alternativen die so ein alu-werk am
Laufen halten können aber auch da würde
die Politik nicht mutig genug nach vorne
gehen also wenn ein neues Haus gebaut
wird warum wird er nicht sofort vom
Gesetzgeber vorgeschrieben dass er
Solarpanel drauf kommen die sind heute
so effektiv und hat der Staat sich daran
beteiligt hier zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel das bringt doch unheimlich
Energie alle schreien darüber hat die
Energie so teuer also in dieser
löskostenlos
sollte man sich überlegen
finde ich
aber ich spiele Lotto ich habe das noch
nicht aufgegeben
tschüss
die Ziegel Dachziegel drauf sind oder
Solaranlagen
in einer Schlosserei im Ort einem Vater
Sohn Betrieb hört man was die kleinen
und mittelständischen Betriebe umtreibt
Juniorchef Johannes Kronberg schloss
seine Ausbildung mit Auszeichnungen ab
er erklärt woran es seiner Meinung nach
haagt die Energiekosten sind ja
gestiegen dadurch einsteigen auch die
Materialkosten die Materialkosten muss
man dann die Kunden weitergeben der
Kunde muss es auch bezahlen ne auch die
Energiekosten für uns sind gestiegen
bezüglich Maschinen und also sowas ne
also wir verbrauchen mehr Strom das ist
alles teurer geworden und das muss alles
weitergegeben werden das kann der Kunde
sich irgendwann nicht mehr leisten ja
genauso wie als mittelständige Betriebe
weniger Aufträge dann am Ende daraus
kriegen ne das ist das Ende
der Schlosser sagt eine Lösung für alles
habe er auch nicht parat es sei halt
alles sehr kompliziert
sage auch immer ich glaube egal welche
Regierungen an der Macht ist im Moment
keiner kann es allen Leuten gerecht
machen am Ende weil jeder hat irgendwo
irgendwas zu meckern ne aber man muss
das Beste draus machen ich glaube die
letzten Jahre mit Corona und auch jetzt
mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine sind nicht
einfach und wir müssen gucken woher wir
unsere Energie beziehen und das ist
eigentlich auch logisch dass es dann
teurer wird ne ich bin auch für grünen
Strom natürlich wir müssen unser
klimaschützen wir müssen unsere Kinder
schützen aber auch zwei Kinder
aber am Ende muss auch bezahlbar sein ne
das ist das Problem
deshalb ist dem Betrieb hier noch
relativ gut geht aufgrund des
Fachkräftemangels mussten viele andere
Schlossereien schließen sondern noch
einige Kunden hier
[Musik]
am Stadtrand von Dortmund sieht man
woran es gerade im Westen von
Deutschland krank eine marode
Infrastruktur statt die Straße hier zu
sanieren hat man einfach ein 10 km pro
Stunde Schild aufgestellt
vier von fünf Konzernchefs in
Deutschland sagen kaputte Straßen und
Schienen würden ihre Firmen am Wachstum
hindern
und diese Straße gleicht einer
Buckelpiste
der Architekt Rüdiger kennt die
Situation vor Ort und als Fachmann auch
die besonderen Infrastruktur Probleme im
Westen Deutschlands
diese Straße ist seit ca 30 Jahren im
Bau befindlich man hat vor 30 Jahren
angefangen die Kanalisation zu machen
und hat vor ich weiß jetzt circa 20
Jahren im oberen Bereich etwas gemacht
dort die Kanalisation gemacht aber der
Termin für die Erneuerung dieser Straße
ist seitdem immer wieder geschoben
worden ich schätze mal der Stadt
Dortmund war es zu teuer und es sind
viele Gelder in Osten geflossen und
viele Baustellen die im Westen waren
sind dann halt geblieben es wäre also
schön wenn das eine oder andere mehr in
dem Westen wieder fließen würde es würde
also hier den Westen auch
teilweise die Infrastruktur die
Straßensituation etwas verbessern wenn
ich alleine auch an die A45 denke dass
man dort also jetzt massive Probleme hat
und dass dort alle Brücken
wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Kürze
erneuert werden müssen da hat man ein
bisschen die Zeit verschlafen
tatsächlich die A45 ist durch eine
mammutbaustelle unterbrochen
hier sieht man was für eine Aufgabe
Deutschland bevorsteht alleine in
Nordrhein-Westfalen müssten 300 runden
erneuert werden die A45 endet bei
Lüdenscheid einfach nichts
die Brücke über dem Tal war summarode
dass sie komplett gesprengt werden
musste
[Musik]
jetzt wird alles neu aufgebaut
aufwändige Umleitung sind die Folge
welche die Transportwege der vielen
mittelständischen Betriebe in der Region
länger und umständlicher machen
in Duisburg sieht man was
Wirtschaftswunder Deutschland eins mit
stark machte die Schwerindustrie die
gewaltigen verrosteten Maschinen und
rohranlagen wirken wie aus der Zeit
gefallen und das sind sie auch während
in den USA digitalfirmen wie Google
Apple und Facebook diesen Gewinner
einfahren wird hier noch mit uralte
Technik mehr schlecht als recht
wirtschaftet nur durch Milliarden
Zuschüsse vom Staat funktioniert das
überhaupt noch
[Musik]
in Marxloh in Sichtweite der Stahlwerke
lebten eins die Arbeiter von dort jetzt
ist ja einer von Deutschlands
bekanntesten Brennpunkten nur jeder
dritte ist erwerbstätig 60% der Bewohner
haben kein deutschen Pass
wer durch die Straßen fährt sieht viele
verlassene Läden heruntergekommene
Häuser
[Musik]
Anwohner erzählen an manchen dieser
Häuser sein dutzende Rumänen und Organen
gemeldet die allerdings nie da sein und
lediglich Sozialgelder kassieren würden
[Musik]
Deutschland wird in den nächsten 12
Jahren 7 Millionen Arbeiter verlieren
weil die geburtenstarken Jahrgänge in
Rente gehen hier rekrutieren die Firmen
jedoch eher nicht
[Musik]
es sind teils Bilder wie aus einer
Dystopie einer verlorenen Stadt
wassilius ist ja aufgewachsen er stammt
aus Griechenland und sagt es seien
einfach zu viele Migranten auf einem
Haufen hier gelandet
wir fühlen uns auch von der Politik die
letzten 15 Jahre hier entstanden
passieren zu viele Sachen
wo man nicht mehr mit zufrieden sein
kann ja und
natürlich es hat ihren Ball unterwegs zu
viele ausländische Anteile sind
wenn man dazu einfach sagen kann so
viele Rumänien Bulgarien und das ganze
gesamte Bild ist nicht mehr so wie es
ist oder wie es war sehr viele deutsche
Kunden von uns wir betreiben diesen im
bisher schon 36 Jahre wir sind
weggezogen in der Nachbarn Orte ja und
das wird immer schwieriger
es ist kein Geld da
ich denke es auch schwierig wenn ein
Unternehmer jetzt in irgendeinen Laden
reingeht und eine Idee hat und die hier
vorzusetzen ne das das wird ja nicht
klappen im Moment dafür zu wenig Geld
hier die Leute die uns sehr sehr schwer
leben
[Musik]
wie eh und je stampfen Binnenschiffe den
Rhein hinauf es scheint eine ähnliche
Anstrengung wäre seitens der Politik
nötig und die Region und die deutsche
Wirtschaft wieder nach vorne zu bringen
[Musik]
im fern Berlin beobachtet Hans-jürgen
Völz vom Bundesverband mittelständische
Wirtschaft die Entwicklung mit großer
Sorge
der Volkswirt kennt die Zahlen genau und
die so sagt er sie nicht gut aus
Deutschland fällt im internationalen
Vergleich der führenden
Wirtschaftsnationen immer weiter zurück
das bestätigt die OCD das bestätigt der
Internationale Währungsfonds und um
diesen Abwärtstrend zu stoppen ist es
dringend erforderlich dass wir in
Deutschland eine richtige reform agenda
brauchen vergleichbar mit Agenda 2010 so
dass Deutschland in den Bereichen wo wir
erhebliche nachholbereich Defizite haben
wir auch dann wieder auf diesen können
an die führenden Wirtschaftsnationen und
zukünftig wieder attraktiv sind für
Investitionen im Standort Deutschland
hier ist der durchschnittliche kleine
mittelständische Betrieb völlig
desillusioniert dass die Politik nicht
willens und in der Lage ist Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen wie etwa die Senkung der
Stromsteuer man muss sich vor Augen
halten die Stromsteuer ist in
Deutschland 40 Mal höher als das von der
EU vorgegebene Mindestniveau und der
Wettbewerb zwingt die Unternehmen
möglichst kostengünstig anzu und wenn
die Rentabilität mit Möglichkeit am
Standort Deutschland nicht mehr gegeben
ist dann denken mehr und mehr
Unternehmen nicht nur ans Aufhören an
die geschäftsschließung sondern
verlagern auch
Völz sagt die hohen Stromkosten steuern
und bürokratie-wust seien nur ein Teil
des Problems es gäbe auch eine gewisse
zukunftsfeindlichkeit auf Seiten der
Regierung
es hat ja einen Grund warum sich
bayern-tech beispielsweise in
Großbritannien engagiert warum BASF in
china investiert es sind nicht allein
nur Energiekosten starre Arbeitsmarkt
oder Bürokratie sondern es sind häufig
Vorgaben die ist Unternehmen nicht
erlauben am Standort Deutschland
Forschung Entwicklung zu betreiben bzw
nur zu ungünstigen Rahmenbedingungen
wenn es hier mehr Flexibilität mehr
Freiheitsgrade seitens der Politik gäbe
bin ich mir sicher dass die Unternehmen
dann auch wieder am Standort Deutschland
in diese Zukunftstechnologien
investieren würden
die meisten Experten und Beobachter sind
sich einig noch geht es Deutschland
relativ gut aber wenn ich jetzt
grundlegende Weichen neu gestellt werden
könne das in zehn Jahren ganz anders
aussehen
auch qualifizierte Einwanderer müssten
die Fachkräfte Löcher stopfen dafür
müssten jedoch jährlich und die 600.000
Wohnungen neu gebaut werden statt wie
2022 gerade mal 300.000
[Musik]
ähnlich wie bei den schmerzhaften
Sozialreformen zur Jahrtausendwende von
denen Deutschland als kranker Mann
Europas galt müsste nun wieder ein Ruck
durchs Land gehen heißt es
[Musik]